One of the things that came out of my
research,
if you truly by the idea that this is a
way of thinking about the world,
like the scientific method,
it's a way of dealing with the world as
a way of thinking about solving problems
in the world.
Then you should be able to solve
business problems with it.
So one of the things I started thinking
about a lot more as I wrote about my
research was how would I take this
logic,
this way of reasoning and apply it in a
business setting,
like in a social setting,
if you will.
So a,
I walked into class one day and I asked
people,
why can't I buy futures contracts in
Rwandan prosperity,
right?
So why is it that when we try to solve
something like poverty or a women's
progress or a education b seemed to
think that we need to use a different
set of tools that business.
So that was one of the questions I had
and I started thinking through,
you know,
how would an expert entrepreneur
actually tackled any of those problems?
And I gave you the example of moment
with you this already,
who is a great example of somebody who
take it exactly like a lot of the expert
entrepreneurs that I studied and ended
up actually solving a social problem
with surveys to a reasonable extent.
Of course,
it's a lot more work to be done.
At least he showed the one way to solve
the problem.
And for me it's a,
it's kind of a two problems in one in
the sense that it also lifts people out
of poverty and it helps women do it.
It empowers women.
So I find that very,
very close to my heart,
if you will.
So if you start looking for people who
have solve social problems and in a,
in a reasonably big way,
and you find the same kind of thinking,
then it begs the question,
uh,
as to why we would not use business
tools,
why would be,
don't use entrepreneurial thinking to
solve some of those problems.
And that line of thought has led me to
an interesting problem that I want to
this post.
And that is because a lot of
entrepreneurs in the social sector think
like entrepreneurs in the for profit
sector,
but somehow the funding part of it is so
different that it makes the social
sector problems very different and
difficult.
And so one of the things I want to think
about is what would have to change the
way we fund problems in the social
sector,
uh,
so that entrepreneurial thinking can
actually do the kind of development that
has been made possible at the for profit
sector in places like India and China.
So that's one of the questions that I
want to leave people with to think
about.
What would it take to create something
that is equally valid to all the
different kinds of credit markets and
innovative financial instruments that we
see in the for profit sector.
I know this is a really bad time to talk
about innovative financial instruments,
but I also think it's a great time for
that very same reason that the same
innovative a mindset that you have in
the financial secretary.
You could actually take it over to the
social sector.
I think something interesting things can
happen and so I do want to give you just
one example or maybe two on that because
close to my heart and you can decide
what to do with it.
Uh,
one example I have is this company
called Looney Uhh,
which has come up with a venture capital
model for funding education in Latin
America.
Uh,
another uh,
instrument that I'm looking at is a
fixed income instrument to fund
education in Pakistan.
As I mentioned,
these are education issues are kind of
close to my heart.
What I want to talk about is the
innovations in funding that are
available in the for profit sector that
are not available in the social sector
and not even innovations things that
were innovations once upon a time,
but things that we take for granted now
they're just efficient ways of funneling
resources into particular companies and
matching up different investors with
different companies.
For example,
let's think about something like a,
you know,
more fuel efficient cars,
right?
So one of the ways,
uh,
you think about how do you want to think
about buying a fuel efficient car?
You can check out all the different
models that are there and you can hear
people pitch by the electric car is so
much better than the hybrid or uh,
you know,
natural gas would be even better or you
can actually have,
you know,
turn on CNBC or a on CNN or the
technology section or something like
that and you and you can listen to
different people pitch you different
things and then you can take your pick.
You can spend a little bit more time and
do some more analysis or research if you
want.
And you can say,
here's the kind of car I want to buy.
You can also think through which,
which car company you want to invest in
a.
But there's no channel that I can turn
on and here,
you know,
two guys from the Congo say,
uh,
talk to me about how they are going to
solve the illiteracy problem in the
Congo.
And I think through which one do I want
to actually back and go home,
do a little bit of research and a couple
of clicks on the computer and I send the
money to that.
One.
We never think about social sector
problems in the same way.
That's the kind of thing,
I mean,
and let's say one of those two guys in
the Congo as a really poor way of
solving the illiteracy problem in such a
way that the problem's solved.
And uh,
you know,
it creates a financially self sustaining
model.
Uh,
there's no way we can just simply create
a franchise of 1200 of those kinds of
schools that spread all over Africa or
we can important to Brazil.
We don't think about social sector
problems though that way and we don't
have any of the channels that
infrastructure that exists that allow
entrepreneurs to not just build ventures
but to grow them and to spread them out
and to create variations through
competition,
things like that.
So I allow a lot of those things and
most of us will recognize those market
mechanisms,
right?
They don't exist in the social world.
It's like really good smart people
reinvent the wheel all the time in the
social sector.
So my question really is that the
essence of entrepreneurial thinking
exists on the side of entrepreneurs
building ventures in the social sector,
but it seems to be very much lacking on
the funding side and that's where I
think I would like to do some work and
some of my colleagues and I are
beginning to work on it and we call
those markets in here.
Would hope.
I just wanted to mention that because I
want to leave like a everything that I
have talked about here on a what to do
next problem and I think for those of us
interested in innovative ideas in
business and especially a,
the logic of entrepreneurs that is going
to be,
for me,
I think the next frontier to think
through how do we bring entrepreneurial
thinking to the funding side of the
social sector?
Uh,
lots of good stuff are happening on the
ground both on the entrepreneur side
that is a venture building side and the
funding side.
But I think there's a lot of exciting
opportunities on the funding side for
entrepreneurs to get in there.
Uh,
would.